In the fourth grade group we carried out a
school project entitled The Festival of Cultures,
which aimed to recognize the different cultures and groups of the
region in order to assess their cultural and linguistic practices.
This required the support of students and parents.
Essential concepts such as culture,
cultural diversity,
multiculturalism and multilingualism were addressed.
Indigenous peoples are also called ethno-linguistic groups and the
National Institute of Indigenous Peoples has identified 68
ethno-linguistic groups in our country based on the language they speak,
the territory where they are located and
other features that make them particular,
specifically in the region of Veracruz has 6 groups,
which are popolucas,
tallintecos,
polotecos,
totonacas,
there are small groups and tepeguas distributed in the state.
During the celebration of cultures,
all school groups were invited to witness the
different stands where they showed the location of costumes,
among other characteristics of each indigenous people.
It was a very enriching event,
as some students recognized themselves as members of the different
cultural groups as well as the cultural diversity of the country.